foreign secretary is with us in the
studio now hello to foreign secretary
thanks for joining us on the programme
this morning um to the outside world it
appears what's going on in kabul is
absolute chaos what's your understanding
well i got a situation update this
morning the
position at the airport is stabilizing
there's been a surge of us and uk troops
we've got 600 extra personnel there it's
critically important not just for the
stability on the ground for afghans but
critically for our evacuation effort
we've made real progress we had 150
british nationals come out on sunday
over the last week we've also had 289
of those afghan nationals who have
served the uk so loyally in afghanistan
and we expect over the next 24 hours to
have 350 more both british nationals and
afghan nationals have worked for us
coming out so the situation is
stabilizing but obviously we're
monitoring it very carefully ben wallace
told me yesterday and again last friday
that we needed something like 1500
people a day to come out
well it it depends if you're talking
about the arap program or nationals
we've had uh and there's nothing it's
chaos though we need to get them out
well actually i think getting our
british nationals out of course there's
something like uh 2000 that the figure
is changing all the time who have
contacted us so that's a much smaller
figure in terms of our app yes we want
to we want to get all of those out as
well arab of course is those whether
it's translators or other
afghans who loyally serve the uk so
doing everything we can but obviously it
depends on the security situation on the
ground
that's why we're putting in 600 of our
own personnel i spoke to tony blink and
the u.s secretary of state yesterday
they're upping every hour and every day
the security that they need including
crowd control to deal with the surge of
afghans what happened yesterday who
who are
seeking to get out
given the taliban takeover what happened
yesterday well i think given the taliban
takeover given the nervousness the fear
on the ground you've seen a lot of
people effectively heading for the door
um and we've got to make sure that we
can stabilize the situation and i think
ultimately british people would expect
us and i'm sure the american public the
same to prioritize our nationals uh
including dual nationals in afghanistan
uh but also those who have so loyally
served us that's what we're doing okay
um a large number of thugs is what i
read in this morning's newspapers that
are on their way to kabul uh this uneasy
piece that is in place at the moment is
very soon going to be shattered what's
your intelligence on that well we don't
talk about intelligence as you know you
must be concerned about it though well
there are reports all the time the
situation is very fluid the taliban have
exerted control far more rapidly than we
expect there will be
dissenting rebel
voices and actions uh what we want to
see at the moment is two things one the
evacuation conducted as stably as
possible we've had assurances at the
higher level from the taliban
through
publicly through the taliban political
commission doha in three or third
parties i spoke to the qatari foreign
minister and the pakistani foreign
minister um they've made all sorts of
commitments in the doha agreement which
dates back to 2020 we expect to hold
into account to that
and secondly then there is the
medium-term strategy which must mean
making sure that afghanistan can't be
used by terrorist groups to attack
neighbours or the west again
trying to provide the humanitarian
relief that the people in afghanistan
need given the hugely unstable situation
you've described
that's going to be very challenging we
won't obviously be giving aid directly
to the taliban we do want to provide
humanitarian relief
to the civilian population and i think
there's a much broader question about
stabilizing that region and how we
engage
with those countries who are going to be
very difficult but will have a stake in
trying to stabilize the situation from
pakistan india to china all with very
different views we've got to show the
international leadership to try and
bring some stability in a positive track
more than that ken mccallum the head of
mi5 is very worried about uk based
groups which um have been radicalised
that could cause problems here in the uk
how weird are you about that well look
we listened to ken and the home
secretary and the law enforcement
operations here attract that very very
carefully um of course what happens in
the middle east we know uh can have a
ricochet effect back in the uk but what
i do know is that uh
the ken and the mi5 team and all of our
law enforcements are absolutely red-hot
on making sure that we protect british
nationals and uh the uk that's our
number one priority
right to be worried ben wallace says he
is i think it's always right the head of
mi5 is alert and sensitive to all
changes abroad that will have a security
implication in the uk okay
i want to go back to uh the people that
are coming out
of afghanistan i've been speaking to a
lot of your colleagues they're
absolutely furious that they say about
20 000 afghan nationals need to return
to the uk because they are either people
that work for us directly or their
families who are in extreme danger if
they stay there yeah is that the sort of
number that you're looking at well the
the total numbers are being processed by
uh through the arab scheme we've got 3
300
afghan
nationals and their families out to date
i think we're the highest
number uh proportionately of all of our
allies so i think it's been very
difficult but we've made good progress
we want to now stabilize that airport
and get as many of them out as we
possibly can but yeah but but look but
look at that number but well i'm not
sure about the number exactly but look
they're clearly in the thousands because
we've got 3 300 out already we want to
get as many of them as we physically can
out but of course it depends on the
stable stability of the situation on the
ground which is why we come back to the
point that you mentioned earlier rightly
the stability at the airport is
absolutely key and i've been working
very closely with ben wallace and the
home secretary to make sure we can do
everything we can give ourselves the
capacity every day to get as many out as
as quickly as we can given the uh the
window of opportunity for that do you
agree with your defense secretary that
sadly some people will be left behind i
think there's always a risk of that what
i'm focused on is just doing everything
physically possible to get british
nationals out to get as many of those
have loyally served us out
and also to think about how we then move
forward with an international strategy
which can stabilize the situation for
the people of afghanistan under what
time scale are you hoping to be able to
do that i think it's difficult to say
because the situation is so fluid we
were all caught by a surprise by the
speed and pace and scale of the taliban
takeover the americans have talked about
the end of august but ultimately we need
to get people out as quickly as possible
as soon as possible and it will depend
on the security situation on the ground
but come back to the point i do think
and having spoken to tony blinken my
opposite number yesterday do think that
the the airport is is more stable today
than it was yesterday and we need to
make sure that we consolidate that uh in
the days ahead okay um given that you
said that not just you but many were
taken by surprise not least the
americans as well how disappointed are
you that our military top brass um
didn't know that this was coming
well it's not just a question by the way
of the military we have a an assessment
process uh we've looked at it for uh if
you since i become foreign secretary
i've been in the nsc's national security
council meetings we've monitored this
very carefully but the truth is uh
across the world people were caught by
surprise i haven't spoken to an
international interlocutor including
countries in the region over the last
week who hasn't been surprised um but
the reality is they predict better after
20 years in the country well yeah but we
we saw a very uh swift change in the
dynamics and of course this has been
part and parcel of the withdrawal of uh
western troops um
but it's also been the way and the
approach of the taliban and and of
course it's been a test for the afghan
security forces all of those factors
have been very fluid but no one saw this
coming uh of course we would have taken
action if we had but
i i get that my question is shouldn't we
have
i i think it's easy to say that with the
benefit of hindsight but the truth is
you're always measuring a very fluid
constellation matrix if you like of risk
factors and
that's the reality
is the taliban an organization that you
can do business with
ordinarily you'd say no um or they don't
share our standards of human rights they
don't
deal with they don't treat women the way
they doesn't deal with china well i
think we're going to have to be
pragmatic as the uk policy has always
been uh we've engaged
through the political commission of the
taliban in doha it's important we
engaged through third parties that's why
i spoke to my qatari foreign minister
we're going to need to be able to send
clear messages and our message is going
to be this afghanistan must never be
used to launch terrorist distracts
terrorist attacks against the west we've
had 20 years of success
in that regard we've had a range of
other successes we've seen 10 million
more children in education that never
saw a school book since 2001 many of
those young girls we've uh
we've cleared 8 million landmines so we
have secured gains in that 20 years
clearly they're now at risk what we want
to do is everything we can through the
full range of diplomatic economic
sanction measures to make sure we can
use as much leverage as we conceivably
have and i'm realistic about that to try
and moderate and exercise some form of
positive influence around the regime
ahead and of course there is still and
it may be a low low chance of this still
these talks that are going on through
the taliban's political commission which
is based in doha to try and make sure
that there's a transitional government
which isn't just purely taliban now i
think we need to be released can't trust
the taliban surely you can't but at
least as long as there's a process that
they're engaged in i think we need to
test it they're a ragtag bunch of thugs
look at they uh i'm not going to dissent
from that view but they are now in power
and we now need to deal with that
reality and as all i'm just saying is we
don't have to be optimistic about it as
long as there is an engagement by that
process we want to test uh whether there
is scope to moderate the kind of regime
that we will now see in place do we rule
out returning to afghanistan in some
numbers at some stage in the future
okay i can't uh take a crystal ball out
and thanks
saying are you going to rule that out we
we we look we we seems what biden's done
we're clearly withdrawing we said when
we went into
afghanistan nato said we'd go in
together we adapted together and we'd
leave together
so we now need to deal with that reality
how sorry are you that you didn't return
from your holiday earlier okay as i said
everyone was caught
off guard by the pace scale of the
taliban takeover um the reality is as a
foreign secretary all foreign
secretaries are in this position when
we're abroad whether it's for travel
for work or for holiday we are there uh
able to respond to events so i was
engaged in cobra talking to foreign
counterparts directly
speaking to the head of our team here in
london i was doing that on an hour by
hour basis and of course i left
as soon as the situation deteriorated
and demanded it
understood but you um and the prime
minister i mean you're the de facto uh
deputy prime minister the prime minister
both of you on holiday at the same time
while afghanistan was going to hell in a
handcart
was that a dereliction of duty no i
don't think that's uh that's the right
description look the reality is would
you describe it well look we we've been
monitoring the situation in afghanistan
uh since the 2020 doha agreement very
carefully it's been very fluid from my
point of view at any num
point in time i will have eight to ten
simmering issues that can bubble up uh
and we always know not like this yes yes
yes yes i'm afraid okay may not always
be in the media eye but actually
situations where we have to give a very
close eye i always have to be one of the
biggest airlifts since the second world
war well and but we didn't predict uh
that we would be doing this on this
scale because of the taliban takeover
but look in retrospect of course i
wouldn't have gone on holiday if i'd
known that being the case equally after
um 18 months and two years of a very uh
grueling demanding schedule i think it's
right the people in those positions try
and take some leave but we're always
ready i'm always ready uh to come back
and of course the key point that i was
making is even when i was away frankly
uh wouldn't have gone away if i'd have
known that i was constantly uh handling
and managing meetings uh talking to
foreign counterparts and uh because of
technology of course able to engage in
every one of the cobra meetings i was
speaking to a former soldier yesterday
who lost both of his legs um in
afghanistan he said he picked up bits of
his mate on the road in afghanistan he
says that it was all for nothing
my heart goes out to anyone that has
served their country and suffered those
kind of losses and seen what he would
have seen um he has served his country
loyally and i think you should be proud
of what he's achieved as i mentioned
before we're there 20 years
we have
in that time not seen a terrorist group
attacked the west from afghanistan we
have seen but what's going to happen
hold on
let's but he about it wasn't all for
nothing 10 million uh girl uh children
in education many of them girls uh eight
million landmines clear we did that with
our partners just so you know for
mothers the
the maternal fatality rate so the number
of mothers that lost their life in
childbirth or in pregnancy down by
almost a half but what no so we achieved
those things but now the question is
with the taliban in place and what are
the levers we've got to moderate what
comes next and to make sure that the
gains aren't lost what do you think so
first my
my answer to him would be is his service
was not in vain but we've got a you know
hell of a challenge now we will use all
the levers that we've got whether it's
economic tools sanctions the diplomatic
leverage i think what's going to be
important in the terms of the diplomacy
is working with all the countries in the
region as well as the traditional
partners india mata
china and russia will matter difficult
interlocutors for us pakistan will
matter all of those have got to with us
work to provide some stability and we've
started that in the security council we
use our g7 presidency we'll use the un
general assembly coming up in september
i think we need a contact group
of those regional and key partners and i
think we need to see
some international leadership and we'll
be working very closely with the un and
those partners to achieve that